fortsetzung folgt das sind die besten
film vom schweizer fernsehen mit seinen
menschen auf dem höhepunkt
persönliches schicksal
[Musik]
ihre grenze untere beruf
das sind geschichten mit dessen leben
und jetzt soll's wieder schwarz um
höhere bergen und großes risiko der
wärme uhr ließ steg wichtigste gibt vor
ihm später im beruf grant und sich so
als bergsteiger einen namen gemacht
welt wie sie die aktie ist sie steht mit
sherpas am mount everest fangen im
erzählt das leben minute durch stande
bringen
wer hätte uns namenlos bleibt die
wegsteckt
ueli steck einmal zwischen alpinistische
höhepunkt und menschlichen abgrund
[Musik]
was ist deine menschen und dass ihre
geschichte war
[Musik]
wir sind im berner oberland
eindrücklichste vor allen altbewährt der
eiger-nordwand für alle die wenig mit
dem blick auf die klinische sind ist
einfach eine wahnsinns kulisse für die
uhr ist der wagen schon als junger
weiterhin große traum
mit 18 ist sehr schmal beruf und sport
politik hat eiger nordwand weitere
revolutioniert vor vier jahren doktoren
jacqueline schwerzmann beeindruckende
film übrigen realisiert der schnellste
mann am berg der einstieg auf die suche
nach dem match
[Musik]
der eigner verlangt auch den besten
alpinisten alles ab eine riesige wand
aus fels und eis alles im ewigen
schatten
schon immer versuchten alpinisten die
nordwand so schnell wie möglich zu
bezwingen
doch niemand hat je gesagt die riesigen
fels fluchten ohne seilsicherung in
angriff zu nehmen
der schweizer alpin ist ueli steck
versucht es nun gar nicht so wenige dass
es je nach sofia und so willkommen und
also konsequent diesen jahres steckt
sich intensiv vorbereitet
jetzt ist er bereit für einen neuen
rekord an der eigernordwand
ein seil hat er zwar dabei aber nur für
den notfall
er will sich ganz auf hände und füße
verlassen und seinen starken kopf
[Musik]
das bewusst rar machen wichtig oder jus
mit sich was passiert ich ganz klar und
das spätere berufsleben oder 20 meter
gefunden wurde
also was kann ich machen dass das nicht
passiert dass ich einfach konzentriert
auf zu hause
da krieg ich bloß daran ihre helfer
haben und genau so mancher funktionär wo
bleibt das gerät für 100 meter aber
möchte das wasser auch überlegt derzeit
der fall ist
der obere wandteil der brüchige riss
unter steck der abgrund es geht jetzt
1000 meter in die tiefe
der götter quergang einer der
exponiertesten stellen
[Musik]
jänner waren die ich die chemie 100
prozent überzeugt dass ihr mann habe den
absturz
im moment nehmen steck befindet sich
bereits im letzten abschnitt der wand
oder elfter sich eigentlich ist das ein
großer das geld bist du dich
[Musik]
der messerscharfe glaubt zieht sich in
die länge
[Musik]
ein letzter springt auf 3900 meter höhe
erst jetzt blickt steck auf die uhr
so ist eben das sagt mir denkt das ist
möglich er denkt maximum sagt der haut
stimmen
die lizenz gilt das heute so nachdem
innenminister sagt laker vom training
her jungenblut und und der aktuelle
titel es sich irgendwo okay das stimmt
die tief stehen und schon ist der markt
zwar auf 27 4
[Musik]
die meisten die zeremonie los was
dahinter steckt die jetzt viel steht
verspielt oder später wird das alles so
abstürzen kann passiert wenn nichts
passiert aber wenn du die somit genau
mit office beschäftigt erreichte mit
unglaublich es ist meine person noch ein
kleider und ich fahre nie jemand anderen
mit mit dem motor mit 80 das dorf 21
völlig sozial unverträglichen aus
hennickendorf 6
ueli steck war früher zimmermann
heute wohnt er in ringgenberg ob
interlaken gemeinsam mit seiner frau
nicole steck ist seit 2008 verheiratet
nicole steck ist auch bergsteigerin
gemeinsam standen sie schon auf einem
6000 schon als sie sich kennenlernten
klettere der stecke im extrembereich
früh war der umgang mit der angst teil
der beziehung
das ist nicole steckt muss ihren mann
mit dem bergsteigen teilen
er ist häufig im ausland unterwegs hier
im yosemite park in den usa
sein ziel ist die riesige felswand el
capitano
er will die wand im speed tempo klettern
entlang der route de russ ueli steck
unternimmt einen rekordversuch gemeinsam
mit dem amerikaner alex holt dem derzeit
besten yosemite kletter speed climbing
hat nichts zu tun mit normalem
seilschaft klettern
beide klettern gleichzeitig zwischen
ihnen liegen oft nur 23 sicherungen
ich habe bald kann sein ja um schnell zu
sein kletterten aufsteiger hofft am
salon
geschwindigkeits klettern heißt keine
zeit zu verlieren
auch nicht in den heiklen pendelt
lehrgängen für die dinos berühmt ist
o
holt geht schon weiter während steck
sich noch sammelt
sie sind auf halber höhe stecke steigt
voraus dann passiert es
daniel krieger tim hughes drückt die
sich eur chf sie und daniel kettiger
abgesetzt und irgendwie schnittstelle
oder dass ich so sein kraft dass das
team eine möglichkeit ist sich trotz des
relativ groß es gibt viele stellen in
der route wird das ganze viel schlimmer
hätte ausgehen können
er hatte unheimlich blick fast überall
hätte er noch viel wasser stürzen können
wir dachten beide sollen wir für einen
rekord so viel riskieren können wir doch
lieber einfach normal klettern
rekordversuch abgebrochen schritt
angehört auch für spitzenkletterer dazu
das linksabbiegen
ueli steck musste dies schon öfters
erfahren am schmerz vollsten im himalaya
dort wo die höchsten berge sind 2007 bei
seiner ersten reise an einen
achttausender versuchte er bereits hier
einen bergsteigerischen meilenstein zu
setzen
an der annapurna bau.de eine noch nie
begangene route durch die gefährliche
südwand warten alleine
[Musik]
als schön weiteren gekündigt wird
richtsteig auf es ist eine gewaltige
wand die vor ihm liegt
im ersten schnee fällt wird er von einem
stein getroffen dann stürzte in die
tiefe
als er wieder zu bewusstsein kommt
vielen der sich selber er steht unter
schock
weil sport
der film robert bosch kommt ihm
schließlich zu hilfe bringt ihn hinunter
ins basislager liebenauer ja ok
unten bei seinen begleiter dank des
helms ist eher glimpflich davon gekommen
eine monatelange vorbereitung für nichts
schon am nächsten tag die abreise ein
jahr ist vergangen
ein neuer versuch agrana borna nicht
mehr alleine sondern mit dem waliser
simon anthamatten sie wollen in der
südwand die gleiche route klettern wie
jene an der stecke im jahr zuvor
gescheitert war
doch das wetter ist schlecht und die
beiden kehren zurück ins base camp
gleichzeitig ist auch eine spanische
expedition am berg unterwegs auch siegel
auf den gipfel allerdings auf einer
einfacheren route
[Musik]
der sturm ist unter euch klagte jetzt
das zelt auf zwei tage später erreicht
die beiden schweizer ein hilferuf aus
sieben 1400 meter höhe einer der spanier
hat ein schweres lungenödem
es fehlen die medikamente
steck und anthamatten brechen auf um zu
helfen um eineinhalb tage dauert der
gewaltmarsch praktisch ohne pause
sie bringen spritzen die dem hohen
kranken spanier das leben retten sollen
anthamatten wird selber höhenkrank und
bleibt zurück steck ist auf sich alleine
gestellt
er trifft den kranken bergsteiger in
sehr schlechtem zustand an die
mitgebrachten medikamente helfen nichts
mehr in der nacht stirbt der spanier
ueli steck bestattet den leichnam in
einer spalte nur knapp überlebte den
abstieg unweit des gipfels erfährt er
was bergsteigen an den achttausendern
heißt trotzdem bleiben die achttausender
auch für ueli steck das höchste aller
ziele
dort will er weiterführen was er am
einiger perfektioniert hat die schnelle
begehung der berger mit leichtem gepäck
im speed tempo dieser ort des
bergsteigens will steckt auch im
himalaya anwenden
beschäftigt dass du führst du watch und
und das ist die fasziniert und dass die
die gaultier für die person das dass du
so machen egal was die andere denkt
medtech das mal probieren wie die
anderer für mich ist der faszination
verdammt viel ca und einmal noch zu
selten persönlich aber das ganz klar
hinterfragen
[Musik]
seine suche nach dem persönlichen limit
ist damit noch nicht zu ende
[Musik]
durch ihn auch am limit wie hat sie der
uhrenstädte letzten vier jahren brach
sich den film dass wir in dem rätsel
sondern macht auch mit ihm
abgemacht deutscher show passiert ist
passiert
ganz wichtig ist dass man nicht weiß ob
man im wahrsten klassische ja ich habe
dich noch bestimmen oder michael und der
schnellste mann am berg da hat er viel
mag lange das ist für dich ganz ein
wichtiger ort der kurs der herrscher
böhme
er hätte eine andere mit brille und er
braucht den zehn minuten ja an der dann
ja nicht gesehen schon gratuliert sagt
verstand doch so leicht ich sehe und
höre ich nicht überrascht wo du so
schnell wie ein studio gesagt ich habe
selber nicht vermerkt kann sie überhaupt
so schnell warum sich das ist untragbar
dass ich hab das vor dir deswegen dass
wir sind auch in die langsam zahlt aber
das geld mitte rund und immerhin noch
schneller und den euro weiter geht und
das ist nicht normal
immer schneller immer wieder die speed
tempo hatte uli schreck berühmt gemacht
vor zwei jahren ist sie nahmen den
weltweit schlagzeilen
allerdings mit eher positive geschichte
es galt und derek lam sherpas am
höchsten berg der welt
hier ist sprach abschieds vom
touristentrubel warum mit dem ueli steck
in richtige und frau
[Musik]
wieder haltestelle publikums
ich werde mit dem ueli steck über die
geschichte wo ihn vor zwei jahren
wirklich aufgebracht hat am mount
everest auf 670 meter ist ein streit
zwischen westlicher bergsteiger und
nepalesischen sherpas eskaliert und
mitbringt der urlaub krankheit ums leben
jetzt lockt auf die dramatischen stunden
mitte bma filmaufnahmen wurde komplexes
nächsten woche zeigen
frühling 2013
es ist ein einmaliges projekt das ulrich
steck im himalaya plant er will den
mount everest besteigen und gleich
anschließend den danebenliegenden lotse
ohne zusätzlichen sauerstoff
[Musik]
steck will die tour gemeinsam mit dem
italiener simone moro bewältigen
ein mit 46 jahren sehr erfahrener
bergsteiger im basislager bereiten sich
die beiden vor
während der saison leben hier bis zu
1000 menschen es sind die sherpas welche
alles vorbereiten sauerstoffflaschen
hoch schleppen und die kletterseile
fixieren
die westlichen bergsteiger bezahlen bis
zu 60.000 dollar um auf dem gipfel zu
kommen und einige den stark wie möglich
mit der sherpas der komplex
was ist denn was ist genau passiert
einem tag wie sie zum thema tiere mal 80
meter schlafen und das ist normal weil
das ist einfach ein guter kommerzieller
sich halt taxi ist der artischocke und
unter dem tag seinen chef aus gestartet
fertig sei und dass sie mir gestartet um
das wusst und dass man den
energiequellen was immerhin 800 meter
längsten aber auch nach aufstiege dass
man das land immer geglaubt dass ich und
dass er nach es endlich zu zum konflikt
geführt
dieser mann schnell wie möglich auf den
7 aber wie europa teilnahme ist
zwischenzeit überqueren das in der vip
loge wo diese genau wo sind wirklich sie
morgen früher starten
das ist jetzt schon die top erziehung
wir sind froh und sabina darüber geredet
aber nicht in die 200 meter über den
querbalken des eos ich sie positiv der
sherpas hat mir gehört oktober touren
und das ergebnis brach aber nachhauseweg
war braucht ja das kann jetzt jeder und
die will ich aber quasi ich selber
verursacht also mich über eine
schneewand überquert und wasser zu der
kritik dass bei abstieg wie ihr wohl
auch unter bewegung ausgleichen oder die
kommerzielle hand das ist
das würde ich schon immer machen ist ein
weil ob sie noch 3 1 fahrer nach der
geheimloge sie hier sind naturfreunde
die seile überquert und einem offenbar
überhaupt schärfer auf die ich zu machen
was ist passiert
durch die wartenden du mit mir und sich
abgezeichnet und ich schäme mich ein
anruf mit suchen und vollzog ag und
erich ab und gewinnt ich starte hätte
einfach und dann immer so hart und ich
dann gemeindlichen haushalt an die
natürlich nach langnau so alt wird und
sich kräftemäßig habe unter der simone
ist aber über die querlatte
mit dem start der 5 wenn jemand mit dem
eispickel herumfuchtelt hast du zwei
möglichkeiten entweder durch teils
blumen wenn du gandhi bist oder du
verhältst dich wie ein normaler mensch
und schreist die person
das habe ich gemacht
ich habe geschrien und dabei ein
nepalesisches schimpfwort benutzt
martin n was macht ihr da die bösen
worte sind via funk im ganzen tal zu
hören weißt du dass simon im hochsprung
also ich denke sagen dass das nicht
passiert ja und im camp 2 eskaliert die
situation
ein mord wütender sherpas macht jagd auf
die steck und simone moro sich zum
status und der krieg hat weil er mit
diskutieren und ja die mir das mal auf
dem schläger diskutiere also ist
passiert und ich gedacht ich kann das
also ich weiß da tippe ich auf mizuho
und ja gedacht
die trainer machen da nicht auch stehe
ich also mit dem bodenlosen und simone
und aktionen die halten die wärme
kontext also durchwegs angst um die
sauberkeit im moment jeder auf
diskutiert und im umgang dass ich durch
sie diskutieren aber da außer dass ich
zuerst ein rätsel um bringen und neue
logo für die anrufe sei bekannt dass ich
wirklich so
haupt stuttgart das ist geheim pitztal
geflogen
das hat gereicht
das sind bilder so voran ohe hat das
vorteile situation derzeit in 70 etwas
passiert ueli steck ist gefangen im
blauen verpflegungszelt umzingelt von
aufgebrachten schert aus
steine fliegen und steckt kann sich
nicht wehren
das hat mir da eine andere risiken die
bringen und durch aussagen wenig machen
so hilflose credo war hat er beobachtet
macht vor dem verpflegungszelt will sich
simone moro entschuldigen für die
schimpfworte die er benutzt
mitten im getümmel versucht eine frau zu
schlichten
die amerikanische bergsteigerin meldet
die bergsteigerin dem komplex und also
das finde ich extrem stark und extrem
mutig dass sie da stritten und sicher
auch wie magische oder ob es der ganzen
geschichte woonio war sehr bedrückt ist
extrem viel westliche bars die genau
daran ak und aber daran sich stand und
danach nötig gemacht
nach bangen minuten ziehen sich die
sherpas endlich zurück und das muss
bewährte berg juli steht das limit
braucht sondern der mensch noch im
streit am everest ist ueli steck völlig
verunsichert er denkt sogar auf höhere
aber schließlich severin wie durch
weitere die einzige möglichkeit zum sich
vor die geister
aber vor zwei wochen versprochen
training ist für den uhri steckt aber
ein rechtsgutachten ries gemerkt dass im
körper und im so viel macht wie früher
solange aber noch richtig mag wieder
erreichen aus verschafften
das ziel hat ihn deshalb zu machen
everest im himalaya trip zurück zu der
annapurna südwand um schon zwei mal
kritisch
das moor schrieb der urlaub schickt
ganze leid und ich südliche wand vom
tödlichsten acht musiker das ist ein
meilenstein im alpinismus so ungünstig
dass kritiker am holistic vorwerfen dass
er gerne topix sie aber alles der reihe
nach
das ist ein taxi mit dem österreich
nicht oft gesehen hatte film zweimal
versucht zwei mal 2003 begangen
wahnsinns kulisse 8091 meter hoch ist
die annapurna die direkteste route durch
die südwand wurde schon von mehreren
alpinisten zu klettern versucht aber
bisher sind alle gescheitert
ueli steck will mit dem amerikaner don
bowie nun die erstbesteigung schaffen
doch am fuße der wand beschleicht bubi
ein schlechtes gefühl
er ist nicht bereit die route zu
klettern
er wird gleich zu hause
also ich gehe jetzt mal bis zum kämpfer
ins um zu schauen wie die bedingungen
sind sie hatten das dorf
die beiden bergsteiger haben auf 6100
meter höhe ein materialdepot
eingerichtet steck war nicht darauf
eingestellt alleine loszuziehen
aber er versucht es trotzdem er kann nun
zwar sein tempo gehen hat dafür aber
auch niemanden der ihm hilft und auch
keinen zeugen falls ihr den gipfel
erreicht
die bedingungen sind sehr gut auf dem
harten firmen kommt steck ausgezeichnet
voran
ich stehe dem moment wo du grüßt jetzt
gar nicht jetzt geht es trocken
jetzt kann ich so fit wie mich und das
auto wieder ist sie die nacht muss mich
immer bewegen und wenn ich das ruhig
machen dass der tag x zu unterschied der
luft versorgt
also ist somit strategie und an die 150
stunden gemacht im unternehmen mit dass
ich noch angst gemacht und bin ihm
späteren nachmittag bini und verglich
sie und dann in vitro also ich find sie
akkus jetzt muss überhaupt eine heftige
debatte musiker und da ist super
jemanden erkennen
damit revanchierte sich perfekt schnell
und ist somit das rund funktionieren
kann die eventuelle ordnung vater und
dann dankt jetzt noch das bild das sind
haben die nach hatte dass ich mich zu
orientieren es bilder kamera und dann
immer das bild gemacht ist der hahn
austritt spiel machen und die damals als
spieler hat mich so ist ein spin-off
dass ich so locker schnell wieder vorbei
ich denke das wäre fast zu wahren das
musste ich mich jetzt mal sehen was ich
wollte sicher alles wird dazu haben sie
das egal
überhaupt steht aber du bist abgestimmt
kamera damit kam reich ranicki und das
sind natürlich aber das land braucht
aber das ist für mich also der schiene
schaut dort umgeschaut und von der
thannen das risiko von akzeptiert ich
werde gleich
das ist uns ganz ab und zogen ihn noch
gestört aber es ist dunkel war vorher
nie geschafft
wir haben gottes überhaupt ist es nicht
in ihrem wahn sehen in der dunkelheit
eine strecke im sport talk shows und mit
landtag sehr sehr viel und ich kriege ja
stehe dass die schifffahrt lang mischten
und alex c noch bis zum gipfel und
schlussendlich bin morgen meine ich bin
einer von bp
und da ist ich hab's geschafft ist das
freud moment findet er sich das
schwierigste gerade gestorben und du
bist ja nachdem sie habe ich nur traurig
weil ich ein spiel heraus zu verraten
und er grüßt die ich zum teil noch fünf
zentimeter dick sie und was da am morgen
zu unterziehen
die nacht ist es schon headquarter
nationen gibt es wahrlich und der
kommune habe und jetzt wenig material
das aus abzählen und das ich erachte
druck oder euch natürlich jetzt solche
fachhändler mit ihnen vertraut macht er
das überhaupt das risiko erwischt es
mich sehr beschäftigt also was das
angeht macht es ist so bitter es ist
sich in unicode und wie du deinen wieder
am markt wurde die in comics oder im
kiez bildern
28 stunden nachdem steck gestartet war
ist er zurück im basecamp
als gott die bestätigung von annapurna
der pilotepisode bei aufstieger oskar
die größte auszeichnung
es gibt aber trotzdem schafften dann
mach das das kritiker journalisten aber
auch bergsteiger kollegen vor dir wo die
und glaube das tut aber zweifelt mit
grüner machen dass neben der pkv dass er
keine bezirks tätig sind
im parkhaus
ich bin der erste gipfel foto ich sagte
mir wohl um damit sowohl hat von der
besser machen aber da man ich soll mich
jetzt in dem moment und die kamera von
orange laut studie bereit wie habe ich
jetzt bewiesen dass ich der weg
überhaupt gemacht also möglichkeit quasi
nur wo man ein künftiger der gps weg in
die ställe rumänisches mitgemacht
die urig ich darf und das tut der ist
brauchen sie wieder zurückkommen und
vorgang dass die pressestelle wäre ich
einfach darum stand der catherine
wandere ich glaube ich so auf die sache
fokussiert dass das vieh und besonnene
gemacht
ärgerlich klar weil sie immer die
zukunft dann will man also ich muss mehr
aufpasst ist das besser gemacht als das
das ich hab es nicht man ist ich für
mich mache man wohne vielleicht trägt
macht im iran zu organisation seid ihr
beide französischer bei abstieg und
jannik graziano und dass der von boehner
die sind noch die reinste macht einzug
geschafft händler oder apotheker seit 28
stunker wie ich das überhaupt möglich
sollen nun ja sie sitzt sollte geachtet
und dass sich hat so adam klein wenn man
sich viel langsamer
vielmehr müssen also auf 688 gehortet
muss lacht das ist aber ich und im
alltag und das trikot für die 2 die
einzige wurde es wirklich konnte
die beurteilen das ist noch nicht
gestellt und mit einer studie nach dem
gerät genau meiner wenn italien also ich
erzähler das ist okay abgeschaut wie vor
seine kritiker sagt es wirklich sagt sie
der studierende unsere oma nein da wir
die nieren oder so dass ich hab ich mit
angela das kann ihnen rückgängig machen
das muss ich akzeptieren ob der ueli
steck auf der armatur maxi ist weiß
letztlich nur marcel helber
ringberg ambri and zu sehen da wohnte
ueli steck ist im büro will die nächste
große plan verrate der ueli steck ist
redner
es muss immer wieder da sie hofft auf
ein gutes omen also die differenz im
altenheim und ali alle 4000 parat wie
viel sie zwar nachts gibt es ja ein also
ein stück genauso wenn machen eigentlich
immer schärfer denn in die
zwischenablage im sektor - dazu ist mit
velo oder frauchen jugendprotesten
begleiteten vielleicht irgendwo leben
das paar sachen zusammen gemacht und
musiker von der alpe 82 gelang ändert da
realist ich würde mit wade über die tat
und die die höhere himalaya andré
hochgebirge ist das für den moment
abgeschlossen
als neues projekt naja wie der große
johnny depp von ina lobte dass ich da
bin
da war dann am main rest wandert ob wir
durch achtung dass ich nach durch und
ein macho wirklich wieder ca
doch durch user das eigentlich nur für
dich als trainingslauf
das ist angesagt ich hatte bisher auch
sehr viel spaß macht eine lange wachsen
und das werden wir mal ab bis hier
wieder alt da weiterzumachen wo
spannende falls dieses projekt stark und
ist ein steak also 80
und einmal mehr weg für die haie
ist das kompatibel mit familie habe also
mit kriegen da zum beispiel das
getrennte es fühlte sich irgendwie
situation habe ja das mag sich zwar nach
expeditionen welches risiko ihn und für
uns
da hat die kommune mit und genießt die
letzten vier jahre schon ziemlich viel
gegangen ist nur für die nächsten vier
jahre weniger versprochen ist ja vieles
schon gut das war epo sei und dem
luxemburger urteil das handy schon sagt
ist nicht egal
auf einem niveau dass du gleich gepackt
und dann mal da macht man da macht man
das risiko auf dem abschluss der sich
über und auch ich glaube dass ich
einfach ab bis sie müssen nichts
schönreden muss es akzeptieren
mit davon jetzt fehlt übernachten denke
dass ich im land ist das mein stab und
das ist einfach so
[Musik]
in der nächste woche sehen wir zurzeit
aber liegen des strohs 2007 immer
dokfilm ihre bewohner kennen gelernt
oder probieren
die ganze welt und celine des strohs
aber im gegensatz zu früheren und alshut
platz da glaube ich dass wir um ihre
interessen ein investor hätten bert
stroß sogar richtig große pläne
das muss ganz neues machen wozu umbruch
an der lindenstraße fortsetzung folgt in
einer woche
[Musik]